this is why I love repurposing content
because ultimately you're able to reduce
stress and get more done while working
less if you create a vertical video why
would you only upload it on YouTube
shorts so imagine if you took videos
from your library combine them into one
larger video you're giving yourself more
opportunities to reach and impact people
with the content and expose them to
other videos and uploads on your channel
that they may have missed
is it possible to upload more videos
while working less the answer is yes and
in this episode of the think media
podcast we're going to be talking about
four powerful ways to increase your
YouTube uploads and get more views while
reducing stress and working less this is
actually part two of our productivity
series and in the first part we talked
about how to record multiple videos in
one day ultimately how to increase your
uploads but in this episode I want to
talk about four tips for repurposing
your existing content in a smart way now
today's episode is brought to you by
21videotips.com that's an incredible
free class that we have sharing today's
best video marketing strategies but I'll
tell you a little bit more about that
later tip number one when it comes to
Smart repurposing one of the best ways
to do this is to turn long form content
into Clips a clip is anything from one
minute to probably 10 minutes and a
great example of this is Dave Ramsey Now
Dave Ramsey is a personal finance
teacher he helps people get out of debt
he's famous for telling people to cut up
their credit cards and what Dave Ramsey
does is a live show five days a week on
personal finance and getting out of debt
Dave actually has two different YouTube
channels and on his Dave Ramsey live
YouTube channel that is where the live
stream happens every day for two hours
or they upload the replay of the
two-hour show now Dave's been doing this
for a long time he's got an entire team
and other personalities but just for
some math to prove how powerful this is
in this last month that channel got 2.4
million views the long form content got
2.4 million views in a month but after
the two hour long form videos are live
streamed or uploaded they're then turned
into shorter Clips which in this case
are uploaded on a different Channel and
so on that channel Dave uploaded 61
videos essentially highlights or clips
that are all around seven minutes each
some of them are four minutes some of
them are nine minutes but here's the
crazy part in a month's time that
channel got
10.3 million views so think about it
across all the uploads about 25 or
whatever it is to do it five days a week
it got 2.4 million views but then
multiplying that content repurposing
that content got 10 million views that
is a 5x return on energy and return on
investment when it comes to the Views
and the impact this is one of the
reasons why we love video podcasting
here at think media because you can
create long form content and then
ultimately repurpose clips from that
content now one of the questions you may
have is should I actually upload Clips
on the same channel or a different
Channel and a lot of times people do it
on a different channel in the case of
Dave Ramsey that's what he does Joe
Rogan is another famous example he has a
channel called j-r-e Clips in his long
form episodes are actually not allowed
to be on YouTube because he signed a 100
million dollar contract with Spotify and
so I don't think there's necessarily a
right or a wrong way I think about Pat
Flynn who during the pandemic started a
live show Daily that was called the
income stream and so every day he went
live and taught something in regards to
online marketing or online business did
a lot of q a and community building and
then he started a separate Channel
called the income stream Clips however
in the case of the think media podcast
we don't want to start an additional
Clips Channel yet so we are keeping all
of our podcast Clips on the same channel
and so for you if you were just starting
out I would recommend not starting
multiple channels but trying to keep
everything under the one roof but this
is something that I think isn't really
right or wrong it's just something to
test pick a strategy and then roll with
it so number one is long form videos
into Clips but number two is long form
into YouTube
shorts what's the difference well
YouTube short is going to be less than
one minute a clip is going to be a
horizontal or landscape video whereas a
short is going to be a vertical video a
cool example of this is Gabriel Perez he
has a channel called
heartworking.dad on IG as well as
YouTube and he has amazing content for
Christian fathers he's a certified
biblical parenting coach and what he
started on was actually Instagram doing
vertical videos what are called
Instagram reels but then he realized how
easy it would be to start a YouTube
channel and upload YouTube shorts Gabe
also started a video podcast with longer
form content on Christian parenting but
then he used an AI tool which we'll
actually be talking about a lot of cool
AI tools which makes this repurposing
stuff fast and easy that'll be part
three of this series so make sure you're
subscribed but he started to take
YouTube shorts out of his longer Forum
video podcast ultimately he's still at
the early stages of building his brand
online of building these social media
channels of building his video podcast
but what's crazy is he already has eight
YouTube shorts that are over a thousand
views and that's been some of his best
performing content so far so think about
it if Dave Ramsey didn't upload those
clips he'd be missing out on so much
more reach and impact and Views think
about Gabe if he wasn't uploading these
shorts he'd already made the long form
content and he used AI to go quickly and
turn the long-form content into shorts
he'd be missing out on more views and
more growth which is critical especially
when you're newer and starting a channel
one California Pastor just crossed 1 000
subscribers on YouTube using this simple
strategy his name is Jeff Morris from
Rhythm Church in Oceanside California he
uses AI software to quickly create
vertical video and YouTube shorts from
his 40-minute sermons that he delivers
on Sunday this strategy led to him
getting five times more views than his
longer form videos we're getting and he
was able to do multiple uploads all from
one longer form sermon and the crazy
thing is this only takes a few minutes
per week this is why I love repurposing
content because ultimately you're able
to reduce stress and get more done while
working less but is there any other ways
we can repurpose our content the answer
is yes and tip number three is content
marathons this is one of my favorite
strategies that literally nobody else
talks about that I've found on the
internet to get the big idea let me ask
you a question have you ever seen a
viral Tick Tock compilation this is
actually where people download multiple
different tick tocks stitch them all
together and upload a 10 or 20 minute
video on YouTube that a lot of times can
get millions of views so imagine if you
took videos from your library combine
them into one larger video and then
uploaded that longer video to your
channel this is why we call this smart
repurposing because no the more you plan
in advance the more that you look down
the road and structure your content the
better the results you can get for
example if you were to create a video
series part one is 10 minutes part two
is 10 minutes part 3 part 4 Etc about 40
minutes of content well you could upload
each of those videos separately perhaps
you could upload some shorter clips from
those videos as well but then you could
Stitch all of those videos together and
upload an extra long video that's 40
minutes this might sound crazy but it's
incredibly powerful and oftentimes super
long content especially education
content can perform very well on YouTube
my favorite example of this that I did
personally was I created a series on how
to plan a video shoot a video edit the
video and then upload the video and I
made it a four-part series then I
eventually stitched them together and
there's ways you can spice this up what
I did was I went back to all of the
previous uploads I looked in the
comments for points of clarity people
were asking for questions people were
asking for and I actually uploaded
transitions that answered the three to
four to five best questions and I kind
of created I was almost like the host of
a four-part series for the super long
content marathon and the content
Marathon was around a two hour video
well that video on think media now has
millions of views it's generated
something like over thirty thousand
dollars in YouTube ad Revenue why well
because it's so long it can have
multiple ad spots and so ask yourself
how could you tap into the power of
content marathons on your channel
another example of this is Evan
Carmichael who's known for uploading a
lot of inspirational compilations and
content from people like Gary vaynerchuk
or Oprah Winfrey one of his popular
series is called 10 rules of success so
he'll make a video of like Oprah's 10
rules of success he'll gather clips from
her all over the Internet Stitch it into
a list and then he'll do part one part
two part three and maybe 10 parts so
then he'll eventually upload a video on
Oprah's 100 rules of success which is
actually all of those videos combined
together now again this may or may not
work for your exact content format but
what I would argue is that there is a
way to do this on your channel for
example if you were a comedian or an
entertainment channel in a year's time
you might upload your five greatest hits
in December around the holidays of like
your top five most viral videos your top
five funniest videos or your top five
songs if you're a musician because it's
kind of like a Telethon a marathon it's
like the episodes of The Walking Dead
are coming out once a week but then
eventually during the holidays usually
they're all stitched together watch The
Walking Dead marathon in black and white
this is a Content marathon and some of
the objections might be well what if
people have already seen this well if
they've already seen it then they don't
have to watch it but two they've
probably forgotten and three a lot of
times new people have subscribed and
what's powerful about this is it's
tapping into more hooks in the ocean
more fishing poles sitting against the
railing on the docks so that you can
potentially if one of the episodes in
the series didn't do very well maybe the
content Marathon will do better you're
giving yourself more opportunities to
reach and impact people with the content
and expose them to other videos and
uploads on your channel that they may
have missed so number one is long form
into Clips those are one to ten minutes
or so number two is long form into
shorts those are vertical videos that
are less than a minute number three is
content marathons and then number four
is to post your vertical videos on other
social media platforms again the goal
here is to take all of the energy all
the creativity and all of the hard work
that you put into creating content and
ultimately get more mileage and impact
and reach out of the one piece of
content you're creating and so if you
create a vertical video why would you
only upload it on YouTube shorts why not
also up uploaded on Instagram and Tick
Tock and Facebook reels you know I
mentioned Jeff Moore's earlier from
Rhythm Church their YouTube channel just
hit a thousand subscribers super cool
milestone for their community and their
church but those sermon clips that are
short vertical videos coming out of his
longer 40-minute sermons are not just
being uploaded as YouTube shorts they're
also going on Facebook they're also
going on Instagram and they're
ultimately able to then encourage people
inspire people bring awareness to that
local church grow followers on the
different platforms and all because
you're working smarter and not harder
all because you're tapping into the
power of intelligently dividing up and
repurposing your content so that it can
reach further than ever before today's
episode is brought to you by
21videotips.com which is a must watch
class especially if you've loved this
content of course we love YouTube the
most here at the think media podcast but
we understand that it's at actually
video itself how can we create great
videos upload great videos on YouTube
but also intelligently spread those
videos across multiple platforms not
just so that we can get some views and
vanity metrics but so that we can
ultimately build our businesses increase
our revenue and so at 21videotips.com
you're going to see a free class of some
of my friends and some of today's top
experts sharing their best video tip of
all time 21 of them all in one class and
it's entirely free and so if you haven't
watched that yet check it out in the
show notes or just go to
21videotips.com now also make sure
you're subscribed for part three of our
productivity Series where I'm going to
be breaking down the best AI tools for
turning one long video into 10 viral
Clips we're going deeper on the topic of
this episode and if you found this
content valuable it would mean the world
to me if you rate review and like this
wherever you watch or listen to the
think media podcast I apprec appreciate
you so much I look forward to connecting
with you in the next episode